My name is Shannon
Rose McAuliffe
and I'm the Manager of
the Student Arts Programs
here at MIT.
On behalf of the entire
Office of the Arts,
welcome and thank you all
so much for joining us
in our newly virtual 15K
Creative Arts Competition
Pitch Finale.
Tonight is our
Eighth Annual Pitch
Finale for the 15K Competition.
Since 2013, The 15K has
served as an incubator
for creative
entrepreneurial startups
and has helped dozens
of student teams
grow their ideas into
influential businesses
at the intersection of
arts and innovation.
We had 17 creative
entrepreneurship ventures
applied to the
competition this year.
Throughout the entire
process, the teams
have demonstrated truly
impressive improvement
and a remarkably collegial,
collaborative spirit.
All of the teams
are to be commended
for their flexibility,
perseverance, and integrity
in the midst of so much
unexpected upheaval.
Following a round of
judging, six finalists
have emerged for the chance to
win $15,000 towards supporting
their projects.
It's been a privilege
to witness the growth
that each team has
undergone on their journey
here this afternoon.
This competition was
designed to provide benefit
to creative ventures
at all levels,
and it's important to note
that all 17 initial teams were
offered the opportunity
to experience the three
key aspects of the 15K.
The first is Idea
Development and Workshops.
Each team received
thorough feedback
from seasoned arts professionals
on their initial applications,
which helped the teams to hone
and clarify their projects.
Teams also attended a
series of targeted workshops
with experts in the area of
creative entrepreneurship,
designed to accelerate all
ventures during the competition
period.
These workshops were
tailored toward topics
such as value propositions,
long-term business
sustainability, and perfecting
the art of storytelling
through the live pitch.
Through these
experiences, our teams
have grown their ideas
and their business savvy
on a broad scale,
and these workshops
are augmented by more granular
individual mentorship.
All participants experience
one-on-one mentorship sessions
with distinguished MIT
faculty and alumni,
creative entrepreneurs,
artists, attorneys,
marketing specialists, and
industry leaders, all of whom
provide nuanced insight
and expertise into helping
teams develop their projects.
And all of this happens through
a platform called Mentorly.
The 15K and Mentorly have
been working together
for three years
now, and the role
they played this year was
instrumental in pairing
our teams with suggested
mentors, data and schedule
management, and stewarding the
mentorship process for everyone
involved.
The teams cumulatively
undertook 39
independent one-on-one
mentoring sessions, in addition
to the aforementioned rounds
of feedback, workshops,
and mock pitch events.
The third, integral element
of the 15K Competition
comes down to a single word,
and that's connections.
Our student teams
make connections
with other students,
with alumni,
and with industry mentors.
This network continues to
bolster and support them,
even after graduation, as they
seek opportunities to bring
their ideas to fruition.
And this year's process,
culminating in today's finale,
would not have been possible
without the expertise,
guidance, and support
from the MIT community.
I'd like to take a moment
and extend special thanks
to our mentors and first
round judges who volunteered
their time,
knowledge, resources,
and insightful expertise
throughout this process.
We've also got our workshop
leaders from Thought Café,
Creative Re/Frame, Spaceus,
and our mock pitch panel.
These people all
spent hours talking
to these teams about their
entrepreneurial experiences
and sharing information
with our teams.
Thank you also to
Mentorly for providing us
with constant support
and an online platform
to facilitate and track
our mentoring sessions.
I also owe a tremendous
debt of gratitude
to my inimitable
colleagues in the MIT
Office for the Arts for
their insights, support,
and for assisting
me with turning this
into a virtual event.
This wouldn't have been
possible without them.
And I'd also like to give a
huge thanks to Teach to Learn,
who were the 2019
winners of the 15K
and they'll be providing
an update tonight
while our judges deliberate.
And on the topic of
judges, enthusiastic
thanks to our estimable
panel of finalist judges
including Josh Roy, Wendy Swart
Grossman, Phillip Tiongson, Gui
Marcondes, Mary Hale, Eran
Egozy, and Mark Steglitz,
who have been and continue to be
champions of this competition.
So before we commence
with the pitches,
I'm going to go over
a bit of housekeeping.
For attendees, competitors,
and judges alike,
please keep your audio muted
and keep your camera off
unless you are speaking.
Each team will have five
minutes to pitch to the panel,
five minutes for
questions from judges,
and one minute for transition.
When there are 60 seconds
left on the timer,
you will hear a dinging sound.
And after the 60
seconds has lapsed,
you will hear the
dinging sound replayed.
And we're going to endeavor
to stick it to this timing
schedule as closely as we can.
After the six
pitches, judges will
exit for a 45-minute
deliberation period
where you'll have an opportunity
to ask questions of our teams,
participate in
audience choice voting,
and to hear an update from our
2019 winner, Teach to Learn.
If you have any questions for
the teams throughout the event,
please submit them
via the Q&A button
at the bottom of your screen.
And now we're going to
do a quick roll call.
Teams, please come
on camera and give us
a wave when you're called.
First up tonight, we have
Jeremy and David with Rarify.
Then we have Alan and
Derek with ArcLive.
Then we've got Carolyn and
Natasha with P(art)ner.
Following that, we have Michael
and Maria with ELEMENTS.
Then we'll have Joe and Iris
with Material Futures Lab,
and we have Piyush
representing UnMake.
Now I wish all of
the competitors
good luck and good skill,
and let's start pitching.
Team Rarify, you're up!
All right, so hello everyone.
My name is David Rosenwasser.
And I'm Jeremy Bilotti.
We are excited to tell
you about our new design
brand called Rarify.
So to give you
some background, I
started collecting and restoring
vintage designer furniture
as a high school student
by flipping chairs
from Craigslist.
Just as I was worrying about how
to pay for architecture school,
a store owner in the
Philippines saw what I was doing
and decided to acquire
all of the inventory
that I had at the time.
That let me start a real
business while helping
to pay for college.
Fast-forward to today,
I've spent nearly 10 years
running D ROSE MOD.
During this time, I
have restored hundreds
of iconic pieces of
furniture, spent thousands
of hours researching,
and changed hands
with over 5,000 pieces.
So David and I go way back.
In fact, he was actually
the first person
that I met at
architecture school.
So as we both studied and
David grew his business,
I was becoming fascinated with
the intersections of design
and technology.
I ended up working at
interdisciplinary design
studios, then at the
Self-Assembly Lab
here at MIT, and with
Microsoft Research.
I became fascinated with how
machine learning and data
science will transform the
way we interact with design.
Now, David and I
are ready to disrupt
the furniture-buying experience
using cutting-edge technology.
So the designer
furniture market today
is worth over $25 billion.
However, there are a number
of issues facing collectors.
When looking to buy authentic
vintage or new designer
furniture, it's really hard for
consumers to know what's real
and what's fake, what's a good
investment and what is not.
Brands that consumers
have come to trust,
like CB2, Restoration
Hardware, and Room & Board,
have been capitalizing off
of knockoffs for decades,
even with high prices.
Let's look at Sam and
Alex, for instance.
Sam bought a high-quality
vintage Barcelona chair for 3K
and Alex spent the same
money on a fake one.
Years later, Sam still
has a fantastic investment
whereas Alex's chair is hard
to sell and has about 10%
of its original value.
That's right, David.
So collectors of the
future want to know
that they're investing
in real value,
and that value needs
to be verified.
They're more informed than
ever, so they need access
to the most collectable
pieces out there.
That's why we founded Rarify
on the values of transparency
and quality.
Our mission is to make the
furniture-buying experience
more transparent and
informative using big data.
So here's how we'll do it.
First, Rarify carries
collectibles of the past,
present and future.
We collaborate with
emerging designers
to make new furniture,
alongside our recent and vintage
inventory.
Next, we show our customers
the authenticity and the value
of each vintage piece,
verified by experts and machine
learning.
Lastly, we sell
direct-to-consumer.
We leverage our existing
supply chain of fabricators,
craftspeople, and shippers.
We have over a
decade of experience
bringing investment-worthy
furniture to collectors.
And now, we're launching as
the design and tech company.
We use data science
to bring collectors
more information, more
clarity, and more confidence.
So how exactly
does our tech work?
Well, our proprietary
authentication technology
uses machine learning
to verify details
about each piece,
such as this chair.
So this means material,
form, condition,
the presence of labels.
It also assesses the piece's
investment potential,
based on things
like market prices
and even the designer's
social media presence.
Finally, it assigns
it a score which
collectors can see alongside
a verified expert score.
Our authentication
technology is going
to revolutionize the way
collectors buy rare furniture.
Thanks, Jeremy.
So what does the e-commerce
furniture landscape
look like today?
There are a lot of ways to buy
a designer furniture online,
and the fastest growing segment
is high-end designer retail,
which includes vintage according
to the US Chamber of Commerce.
Now there are two primary
competitors, both of which
are growing rapidly.
1stdibs sells high-dollar
items within a luxury market,
whereas Chairish is more
oriented toward décor
and lower-value
items in comparison.
Rarify is a disruptor,
setting a standard
for authentication
and transparency
unlike the competition.
Now, part of the market growth
is because there's $350 billion
in high-end collectibles.
Now our business model relies
on commissions from our partner
dealers like D ROSE MOD,
Rarify's in-house inventory,
new designer collaborations, and
revenue from our authentication
technology.
And opportunity from 15K will
provide critical rocket fuel
allowing us to further
develop our back-end tech,
and our first designer
collaboration.
Lastly, with our skills
complementing one another
and our passions going
in the same direction,
we are ready to grow
Rarify into something
that is truly special.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Thank you so much!
And now, we'll have some
Q&A from our judges.
Mark.
The vintage purchasing of
furniture for collection--
a significant part
of the market?
Or do people just
buy furniture for use
including vintage furniture?
So, we're trying to look at--
so I have a pretty
extensive background
in dealing with this
furniture and the reality
is that for many
of these pieces,
they are indeed
investments, that people
look at as both something that
they can look at everyday,
but also as something that's a
collectible piece that someone
is concerned about their value.
And I have customers
pretty frequently
who ask what kind of
Eames lounge chairs
should they buy based upon
collectability and rarity.
And so that's something that
we're hugely attentive to, as
well as applying those
ideas to the new collections
and how we engage collectible
designers in new collections
as well.
Wonderful.
Phillip.
Thanks.
For me, what's
interesting about this
is this idea of an
authentication tech,
that there is some way that
through machine learning
you can create something
that couldn't be fooled.
So a lot of that has
to do with learning--
having a lot of access to the
data about the original stuff,
as well as, how does anyone
trust your authentication?
If there's one thing
I do know, there's
ways to fool verification,
facial recognition.
And so, if people were
able to study your process,
couldn't they just find
a way to fool your tech?
Yeah, I think that's
a really good point.
I mean, part of our
mission is definitely
to promote transparency
and expose all of the data,
perhaps, that we
use in a way that
helps give people confidence.
Obviously, there's a
limit to that transparency
because it is
intellectual property
and we want to preserve that
as part of our business.
But on the consumer end,
we will be prioritizing
sharing which features
we're looking at, and also
documenting each piece
to a higher standard
than what's on the market today.
So you might be able to see the
piece that you're looking at,
identify every scratch, spin
it in 3D on the website,
and also understand the
features and the decisions that
went into scoring that piece.
How we can keep it
private and protect
our IP is that the data
set that we're using
is actually one that
we already have.
So we have a whole
collection of images
and labeled data that we
can work with already,
and start training our
models on right away.
And that's all taken
by us, and by David,
over the course of his
tenure running D ROSE MOD.
All right.
Josh.
So I see that a portion of
your business, while some of it
is existing furniture, you
have an interesting side
of this business that's tied
to designer partnerships
and collaborations.
Can you speak a little bit
more about your arrangements
with those designers,
how you're sourcing them,
how they're compensated, and
what that side of the business
looks like?
Yes.
So we have not-- to be
clear, we have not formally
brought on our first
designer collaboration
yet for new pieces.
But the idea is that, as far
as the general resources,
we have an existing supply
chain of shippers, fabricators,
warehouse storage,
et cetera, that
exists utilizing the resources
from the existing business.
And then as far as
bringing on new designers,
the main initiative we
want to bring forward
is representing both an
up-and-coming and desirable
group of new designers, but also
a diverse range of designers.
So the idea is, how do
we bring aboard people
who we feel like will be
developing collectible pieces
of the future?
And we will use our
own in-house criteria
and also make sure
that the royalties are
ideally better than what is
typically offered in industry.
And we understand that that's
an issue facing designers today
as well.
Yeah, and what's really
interesting there also,
is that we can have full
control over these pieces
and document them
extremely thoroughly.
So we can kind of communicate
how they're authentic,
how they're rare, and
how they're unique,
and then using the
data that we've
trained our machine
learning model on,
we can also come up with the
score for these new pieces
and anticipate that they might
have a particular investment
value for someone.
Yeah, and the analogy today
is, we're looking at the idea
if you were to build a company
like Noel or Herman Miller
today, what would they have
done and how would they have
developed those relationships.
So we're looking at innovative
up-and-coming designers,
but also embedding
technology, trying
to make that streamlined for
consumers direct-to-consumer,
and also using
in-house fabrication
and fabricators so
that we don't need
to charge for third-party
fabricators and so forth.
Wonderful.
And I believe we have
time for one more.
Let's have Wendy.
Though I just heard
the 60 second ding,
so you have one minute.
First, David, Jeremy, so fun.
So fun to see how it's all gone.
Thank you.
Quick question for you.
I'm curious-- first
off, Roadside Antiques.
I think you guys need to be
on there, that would be really
great to get them as a client.
I'm curious about though,
the monetization of this.
Who's going to be
your first customer
and what are they going to pay?
Is it an ongoing
subscription, what's the deal?
OK, so there are a few
different business models.
The first one,
straightforward, is
we will be approaching
this as a business
and rigorously going through
advertising, social media.
And so a lot of
the initial revenue
will be coming from taking
a commission of the existing
sales from the
previous business,
and that will help fuel both,
along with hopefully with 15K,
the new designer collaborations.
So the initial will
be the vintage pieces,
and then immediately we'll
start bringing in designers,
bringing about
collaborations, and we
hope within the first
one to two years,
the majority of our business
will then transition over
to the new
collections so that we
can focus on emerging
designers and new, rare pieces.
OK.
Great.
Wonderful.
Thank you all so much.
Thank you to Team Rarify.
Up next, we've got ArcLive.
Thank you everybody.
Hello everyone.
My name's Alan,
and I'm going to be
talking to you about ArcLive.
So as a quick
introduction, ArcLive
is a video conferencing
research tool
that helps historians conduct
their research internationally
by providing live access
to non-digitized documents.
So we're basically like Doctor
on Demand, but for research.
So most documents aren't online.
And if you really want
to learn about who
an artist was, what
they were like,
you'll look at their notes.
On the left here, we have
a Vitruvian Man, which
came from Leonardo's notes.
And usually if you
want to access these,
you're going to-- it says on the
right there underlined, likely
that you'll need to visit the
research room to actually see
these notes.
Most of them aren't online, and
so your average reading room
looks something like this.
You have hundreds of
thousands of documents stored.
This is a repository where
they're readily accessible,
and then long-term they're
put in depositories.
It's kind of like Indiana Jones
and the Ark of the Covenant
where they wheel the Ark
into that giant storage room.
This is an archive.
This is basically
what they're like.
And they measure--
usually, they don't even
know how many
documents there are.
They measure them in cubic feet,
that's the easiest way to do it
because nobody's ever
counted them all.
And just as an industry,
document imaging
is about a $21 billion market.
Our early accessible market,
we estimate it $350 million.
We split that into
two groups, which
is the Traveling Researchers,
so historians, genealogists.
And then, research firms.
That's let's say, you just
want to contract someone,
you can hire them from there.
So on average, less than
10% of archival documents
are available online.
And the reason for that
is usually archives
can't afford the
digitization costs.
If they're lucky, they'll
get a grant to do it,
but then they have to manage
those documents forever.
There's a recurring cost
associated with that.
But also have to
worry about copyright.
Usually documents acquired
within the last 30 to 40 years,
they didn't expressly get
those copyright permissions
to digitally distribute.
And so as a result if
somebody wants to research,
it's filled with
risk and uncertainty.
Nowadays with long
flights that you
have to deal with
to physically visit
the archives, especially
internationally, most archives
have restricted hours so
like 10:00 AM to 4:00 PM.
We actually heard
one researcher who
was so worried she
wouldn't have enough time
to conduct her research that
she opted to skip lunch for five
days to maximize her time in
the archive, which is crazy.
And then they have to worry
about the copyright, too.
And so combined with
the coronavirus now,
we're starting to see how
valuable online accessibility
tools can be.
We can never go back to the
way things were before this
and that creates a really
unique opportunity.
And so we develop a new
protocol that we call
controlled remote visitation.
This is our
prototype on the left
here, which allows you
to work with a surrogate
to access documents
in real time,
and this circumnavigates
the copyright restrictions
because this is a
form of live access.
We aren't making
permanent replications.
So, what we do.
Normally, it would
cost about $1,800
to travel, say from to Boston
from the UK, about $60 bucks
an hour.
We cut that in half.
We charge $35 per hour for our
service, which you can then
take your travel
budget and use it
to access different
geographic locations based
on the collections they
have, rather than spending it
all in one place.
So most other companies
focus on the public domain
or the highest-priority
documents that are available
now, which is about 10%.
We focus on everything else.
Everything that you
want to digitize,
but it isn't worth
it, or else things
that are just never
going to be digitized.
As far as our technical stack
goes, we have the Hovercam.
These are the
workstations we issue.
For our back-end,
we're using vMix CALL,
is what encodes the video.
And then we distribute it
using Twilio, an online video
platform.
And we're going to be
using Google AutoML later.
I'll talk a little
bit about that later.
Excuse me.
How do we prevent screenshots?
[ONE MINUTE WARNING BELL]
One minute warning.
The video game industry
solved this a while ago.
Water marking.
Alpha channel layering
is what it's called.
So we don't have to
worry about that.
We can use this and
have an active ticker
to track who is doing that.
As far as partnerships,
we already
have our first pilot with
the Thoreau Institute
at Walden Ponds.
Henry David Thoreau.
Walden Pond in Mass.
Long-term, we want
to partner with
several other organizations.
And then, as far as
corporate partnerships,
we're looking at the
Library of Congress
who legislates
copyrights, as well
as Google and Ancestry.com.
Our roadmap for the
next three years--
pilot in Boston, 10 archives.
Spread throughout
the US in year two,
and then move
internationally later.
This is our team.
My name's Alan.
Derek is a Sloan
Fellow with MIT.
I went through the
PlayLabs Accelerator.
And that's ArcLive.
Thank you very much.
Thank you so much, ArcLive.
I'd like to open it up for
Q&A from our judges now.
Alan, if you could
stop sharing, please.
Here, hold on.
Here we go.
Let's see.
Hold on, we can do it.
I believe in you.
There it is.
Perfect.
OK.
All right.
Do we have any
initial questions?
Mark.
I'm a curator, and I'm
interested in a piece of art
and need to do some
research in the archives.
Do I have enough information
to tell your research assistant
just to do-- if you excuse the
expression, the grunt work--
get to the source
of the material
or are you expecting
the researcher
to do a certain amount of
interpretation of his or her
own and formulate conclusions?
So, good question.
Who's still conducting
the research?
We function as an
accessibility tool.
And so the surrogate that
we have onsite, the research
assistant, their
job is to make sure
that they can
provide safe access.
The researcher themselves,
being the subject matter,
they would be the ones
responsible for interpreting
what they're seeing and
then determining what
to do next with the research.
So they have to have
enough knowledge
to point your research assistant
in the right direction.
Yes, so it would be
up to the researcher
to request those documents
from storage to be
pulled into the reading room.
And then we will help
researchers do that.
We work with the archivist to
pull documents that they need.
And we specifically help
with the discovery process,
of figuring out--
usually, the discovery process
of going into an archive,
you're looking for
what sources you
want to use to cite or include
in, say, a historical novel
or something like that.
I can maybe give just a
very quick, specific example
to this.
My family's really big
into genealogical research,
and we read recently found
a History of the List Family
at a very small Ross
County Historical Library,
just outside of Columbus, Ohio.
The problem is due to
copyright restrictions,
they only have one
physical copy onsite.
And so the only
way we can access
that is to physically go there.
And with a tool
like ArcLive, what
we'd be able to actually do
is call in their one volunteer
who's there from
8:00 AM to 6:00 PM,
would be able to actually
open up that resource
and make it available
to us for a paid fee.
All right, let's
hear from Mary next.
Hi, thanks.
I was curious how you determine
to pay for the archive
assistant, and if part
of your calculation
had to do with the
locations of major archives
that people would be
using, and the cost
of living in those locations.
Good question.
So we average the
pay at $15 per hour.
These are entry-level
research positions,
so all the money
that would have been
going to the flights and
hotels is brought back in
to create sustainable
jobs in the industry.
That may vary over time.
One of the things that
we're looking at doing
is increasing our prices
from $35 per hour, up to $50
per hour with add-ons
such as OCR translation,
or OCR tracking, real time
translation, which is better
than doing research in person.
Being able to scan
a page, metadata
extraction because that's
transformative in nature.
We can save metadata, and we'll
just hand that to the archives,
you know we'll just
give it for free.
And then keyword extraction.
So if you're
researching John Smith,
if we find Jonathan
Smith we can say,
hey, this is 92% relevant to
your research topic, which
is where the Google
AutoML comes in
and that will allow us
to dramatically increase
our wages.
Just to follow up
on that real quick,
there's no real
one-size-fits-all approach
here.
So we're going to
have to look closely
at the different archives we're
working with, whether those are
large-scale national
museums, or whether we're
looking at smaller, more local
institutions, which might not
necessarily have that same
demand as some of the larger,
national archives.
How about Wendy?
Thanks, guys.
Interesting.
Really interesting.
Curious about the
hardware that's
going to be involved,
actually on the site.
And the training that
you're going to have
to give the local folks.
Sure, want to see it?
This is our hardware right here.
I have one next to me.
This is the Hovercam
Solo 8 Plus.
This is what we're using.
I was going to use it
as my video camera,
but then I wouldn't be
able to show everyone.
The other is--
I'm using it right now.
So I've personally tested
out all the hardware
that we're going to need.
It requires a pretty beefy
laptop for a workstation,
because you're encoding it and
then you're distributing it.
So the hardware--
My question is like, the
place in Columbus, Ohio
is going to need to get
one of these pieces?
So, yes.
We will be working
directly with contractors.
So issuing workstations
to the assistants
who are going to be doing this.
Another option which
we might do depending
on how frequently
it's used is assigning
a workstation per archive
is another way to do it.
We're still investigating
that on what's most efficient.
All right.
And that is all the time we have
for this round of questions.
Thank you so much, ArcLive.
Now I would like to welcome
to the virtual stage,
Carolyn and Natasha
of P(art)ner.
Thank you all so much
for joining us today.
We're Team P(art)ner.
I'm Carolyn.
I'm Natasha.
We have all been
moved by good art.
But what happens
when things go wrong?
The city of Seoul
spent $1.4 million
commissioning renowned
artist Frank Stella
for a public sculpture
and the community
was so offended by it.
The city had to plant a
ring of trees around it.
Unbelievable, right?
This goes to show that we don't
always connect with the art
that we see and that large-scale
art is hard to create.
We're not getting what we
want out of the $2 billion
that we spend on
public art each year,
given white men constitute a
majority of local art rosters
and galleries.
These trends reveal
that art commissioning
as we know it
prevents art seekers
from finding art creators.
As a consequence,
artwork in public spaces
doesn't represent local
neighborhoods in our cities.
My experience as a real
estate design manager
speaks to this consequence.
In looking to create memorable
and local experiences
for our customers,
I found the process
to be time-consuming to
manage, as items were often
lost in translation between the
development and artist world.
Most critically, this
extensive process
did not always result
in rewarding art.
What I thought were my
singular frustrations
were actually echoed
throughout the industry
as we spoke further
with both sides.
It's inspiring to us that
the importance of art
is affirmed by city governments.
360 of which mandate developers
spend 1% of construction
costs to provide public art.
P(art)ner sees this as an
opportunity for local talent
to represent a neighborhood
and increase both real estate
and social value.
But the benefits
don't just end here.
Research shows that good
art can create destinations
like Naoshima Island,
increase property values,
or even stimulate the
broader municipal economy.
P(art)ner aims to harness
the power of art, culture,
and performance to enhance
the urban experience while
increasing real estate value.
We celebrate local
creative talent
and we do this by helping art
seekers discover, connect with,
and commission the
most promising talent
to move their projects forward.
P(art)ner comes in with a
solution that connects buyers
looking for local large-scale
art, and sellers who create it,
as a re-imagined 21st century
public art gallery that
democratizes art commissioning.
Buyers of art looking to
distinguish their projects
can virtually discover local,
pre-vetted, high-quality and
community-oriented creators
of art who know and understand
the neighborhoods they
live and create in.
Buyers and sellers
engage in three features.
Discover showcases project
proposals and portfolios,
offering more opportunities
for seekers and creators
to find each other.
The Connect function
matches portfolios
with proposals and
goals, providing
collaborative communication
of project vision.
The Commission feature gives
fair pricing and clear steps
to manage contracts
and deliverables.
We envision a world
where everyone wins.
Art seekers have
direct and fast access
to a broader, vetted
local talent pool.
A democratized art
commissioning process
allows local artists to
help set properties apart,
which then improves
the public realm
and leads to place-making
with a purpose.
We're competing against creative
place-making agencies, art
consultants and art
commissioning platforms
that often only manage one
portion of the process.
But our competitive advantage
empowers art creators
to take charge of
their own success
through features like
accessing a wider vendor
ecosystem, curated
educational resources,
and a protected marketplace that
allows both sides to be bold.
Our business model operates
a freemium subscription
and fee-based pricing.
Art seekers pay a
flat subscription fee
to access creative talent
through commissioning
and a project execution roadmap.
We hope to grow our
seekers and creators
pool so that we
can be in 10 cities
at the end of the third year.
So who are we?
We are deeply invested in
P(art)ner because it marries
our core personal missions,
bringing together empowering
emerging artists,
curated place-making,
and responsible real
estate development.
Given my experience as
an artist, architect,
and real estate developer,
I know the ins and outs
of complex art
projects and how tricky
that can be for both
sides to manage.
I'm a policy wonk
and startup lover,
well-versed in bringing
together unlikely partnerships,
but also invested in
closing the racial wealth
gap for black and
brown communities
based on experiences working
in economic and workforce
development.
The competition
funding will help
us establish our
virtual presence
and demonstrate
our first project.
To scale up, we
will first continue
to compile our online database
of seekers and creators,
then design a fair
commissioning process,
and finally, pilot with a
percent for art program,
Seeker.
During this time of great strife
and uncertainty, many of us
are turning to art as an
escape and form of healing.
We at P(art)ner want to play
a major role in providing
a re-imagined gallery to
help current artists weather
the storm and ultimately
enliven places through art.
Thank you so much for your time.
Thank you.
Thank you both so much.
All right, let's hear
from Eran, please.
Thanks, this sounds
really interesting.
I guess a couple of questions.
One is you talked about
focusing on large-scale art,
and I was wondering if
this is the main focus
that you guys have or is
that just the beginning
that you see for your business.
And then the second
question I have actually
has to do with
what's potentially
interesting about your
business, is connecting people
across different locations,
but at the same time
you're talking about
the need for local art
so that the local artists
understand the local scene
and that's how it works.
But that actually seems to limit
you because then basically what
you're saying is, for
this to work well,
you need local artists,
but then the network effect
is not that interesting
anymore because we're just
talking about local
artists and in localities.
So I was wondering if you could
address both of those points.
Sure, I can take that.
So in terms of
large-scale art, I
think we were very
deliberate in addressing this
because we really want to
be careful about not being
associated with smaller-scale
art, which I think
has a lot more competition
of what's already
being placed in the market.
And then also
recognizing that one
of the biggest issues in art
commissioning is funding.
And so it was a very
interesting journey for us
to realize that on one
hand, artists are always
looking for funding,
but on the other hand,
in the real estate
development world,
there is all this funding
that's been bookmarked.
And so the project range can
go from $50,000, on average,
to $2 million that's
being mandated
to be spent per project.
And then in terms
of the local, I
think that it's recognizing
that for example, the 500
artists that are
given for public art,
they do tend to
be national scale.
So we just want to
recognize that we
want to be more mindful
about the artist process
in deliberating
and communicating
with the community so
that the art project that
is being created is more
reflective of the neighborhood.
But then also
addressing the fact
that there is a slight bit of
diversity issue in that pool.
Wonderful.
Next, let's hear from Gui.
Thank you for the presentation.
My question it's a
little similar to Eran's.
I just want to develop
that about a local artist.
I think it's a great idea
to connect local artists
to public art and do that more.
There's a whole issue
of gentrification
in the culture of communities.
I live in Brooklyn,
for instance,
and this is a
constant discussion
about how to represent the
communities that were already
lived-in, so the neighborhoods
are being replaced, et cetera.
Something that's good for the
community not necessarily is
going to be good
for real estate--
make something more expensive
and desirable as an investment.
Probably if you put one of
your examples, Yayoi Kusama's
big pumpkin in front of
a building in Brooklyn,
that's going to sell
for a higher price
than if you get a local
artists, which could eventually
be good for the neighborhood.
Say how you see that issue.
Yeah, absolutely.
Just jumping in here.
That's a question that we've
been thinking a lot about, too.
I think ideally on our platform
as we're bringing together
local creators,
or they don't have
to be necessarily local
or emerging, but as long
as we're widening
that pool that is
accessible to large-scale
art seekers, that's really
what we're in the business for.
But also specifically, one of
the features that we're still
flushing out is
thinking through, OK,
so if you have a large-scale
project that you're putting up
as a proposal, hopefully you
can engage several artists.
Right, and so there might be
five-- some local, some not--
who are also sharing about their
community and social practice,
and that might actually
be a really great way
to engage the
community through art
that helps with the developer's
approval process in that.
So we're really hoping to open
up an opportunity for seekers
to really engage,
and meet and share
their visions with several
artists through the process.
All right, let's hear
from Phillip please.
Hi.
The piece that really--
I think is the most hard
for me to understand
is, you even mentioned you
have a two-sided marketplace,
which, you know, how do
you build credibility?
Right?
How do you find a way for
both artists to think,
like, I can get my stuff
here and how do you
get developers who
are used to going
to a certain set of
art buyers that they
trust to go to here instead?
I think that that's
the biggest question,
and I didn't see anything
in the proposal that
really addresses that head on.
This is our last answer.
Carolyn, do you want
to take that one?
Yeah, so we are starting
off with our strategy
working with non-profit
organizations,
and also working with
local developers.
So we're really excited to
pilot with Sebastian Mariscal
in Somerville.
So he's launching a
development called
CALA, which is really centered
around community and art
and he has over 400
square feet of mural space
for artists to fill.
And so we want to be partnering
with mission-driven developers
to start off with, and
we also have connections
with great non-profit
organizations
like the Dorchester Art Project.
And so they have
artists in residence
that we would love to work with
and feature in our platform.
So that's our scale up strategy.
Yeah, and then speaking to
the developer point of view,
I think that the current
practices right now
is basically a
developer will either
choose to spend a lot of
money on an art consultant,
or if their budget is
about $100,000 or less,
then they will take
it upon themselves
to find the artist which
means that they're not really
optimizing this opportunity.
And the most interesting
thing that we've
heard in all of our
research interviews
is the fact that even when
developers are spending up
to $500,000 in just
consulting fees,
they've always mentioned
that at the very end
they were unsatisfied with the
amount of art that was catered
to the local community.
Because I think that
there is a huge branding
opportunity that's being
missed by developers
because a lot of them do want to
capture and show that they have
good faith towards the community
and if you're engaging artists
on a national scale,
you're not really
optimizing for the
community buy-in.
So I think there's
definitely a mix that
needs to be had in how
you structure your art
and where you want
to be placing it,
but there definitely is a lack
on the local talent right now.
All right.
Thank you so much, P(art)ner.
Next up, I would like
to welcome Elements.
Hi everyone, I'm Maria.
I'm Michael.
And we are Team ELEMENTS.
ELEMENTS is design
learning in a box.
ELEMENTS unlocks the full
potential of every student.
Our kits teach creative thinking
to students ages 10 to 14,
preparing them for the
emerging jobs and challenges
of the 21st century and
developing their human skills
in the age of automation.
Parents and teachers
increasingly
acknowledge the value
of design education.
In the short term,
they see students
build fundamental
design skills and engage
in project-based learning.
Schools see higher graduation
rates and improved test scores.
In the long term,
whether students
become designers
or anything else,
they build creative
problem solving skills,
they build a lifelong
appreciation of design,
and they hone their spatial
and iterative thinking skills.
Despite all of that,
arts education in the US
has been on a steady decline.
As of 2008, only about a
quarter of graduating seniors
reported having any access
to a visual arts education.
And outside of public
school systems,
access to design education
is expensive and exclusive.
Current options like
university pre-college programs
or a specialized creative arts
school can cost about $2,000
for only a two-week course.
That's why we've come
up with ELEMENTS.
Our kits teach different
elements of design,
such as deployable
structures, stop motion,
and pattern design through
open-ended challenges.
ELEMENTS has a three-part
value proposition.
Design for All.
ELEMENTS brings design thinking,
project-based learning,
and creative problem
solving to future creatives,
future professionals, and
future everything else.
Tactile Learning.
ELEMENTS offers physical
learning materials
and tactile design
challenges paired
with an online
platform for students
to share their creative work.
And finally,
ELEMENTS is designed
to develop the uniquely human
skills of the 21st century
professional.
So, why us?
We believe that we're uniquely
suited for this venture
and we are really
motivated about this issue.
We truly believe that
everyone should have access
to design education.
We will implement our own
design teaching knowledge
and techniques into
the logic of the game.
Our venture actually
began as a partnership,
where both Michael
and I were looking
at experimental teaching methods
and together we ran teaching
seminars for MIT students.
That original collaboration
grew into our current venture.
So ELEMENTS has three
cultural touchstones.
The first, ELEMENTS is generous.
Serious design education
demands an openness
to outside voices
and unorthodox ideas.
The second, ELEMENTS
is approachable.
Design is often considered
elite or snobby.
We try to defy those
stereotypes, both in access
and our attitude.
And third, ELEMENTS
is experimental.
Our commitment to
experimentation
applies to our teaching
practices, our design
practices, and our
venture at large.
So to those ends, we've
assembled a team of mentors,
both within MIT and in
the broader community,
for helping us grow the
venture and maintain
those values moving forward.
So back to the kits and
a few of the prototypes
we're working on.
This is the curriculum for
Color, Material and Pigment
Formulation.
With this, a
student would go out
into their local [INAUDIBLE],,
gather a series of objects,
and then have the
resources and instructions
to transform those objects into
workable paints and pigments.
Another prototype here that
looked at rule based drawing,
we tested in the fall
within MIT MArch students,
and then again over
the winter at MIT
Splash with junior high and high
school students from the area.
OK, so now let's have
a look at the market.
The US toy market averages over
$20 billion dollars per year,
with building sets,
games, and arts and crafts
accounting for
25% of that total.
Our research shows that there is
a trend in educational products
shifting away from creative
subjects to science
and engineering subjects by
junior high and high school,
leaving older students without
access to creative curriculum.
That's your one minute warning.
So that's where we see
ELEMENTS fitting in.
We believe we will occupy
this gap in the market,
and we believe that design
learning and creative thinking
should be encouraged
at all ages.
That's why our products
offer creative curriculum
to an age group where these
subjects are being phased out.
So ELEMENTS will launch as a
direct-to-consumer online sales
company, and we'll be
targeting middle school
students and their
parents and families
as our beachhead market.
This is a sweet spot for us
because junior high students
are still exploring a
variety of subjects,
their parents are
highly involved,
and they're not yet fixated
on college admissions.
In years two and
three of the venture,
we plan to expand our market
and offer wholesale curriculum
to public schools
and corporate teams.
So with the help of MIT's
Creative Arts Competition,
we'll develop our initial
line of six curriculum kits,
anticipating a
monthly subscription
model in the future.
We'll establish partnerships
with manufacturers
and begin shifting our
production out-of-house,
and we'll finalize
our at-home prototype
kits and our online sharing
platform for a soft launch
this summer.
And finally, what is our vision?
Well, we imagine a society which
supports future generations
of entrepreneurs, designers,
makers, and innovators,
and where access
to design education
is available to all,
regardless of background
or economic status.
Thank you.
All right, thank
you so, so much.
And let us turn to
our esteemed panel.
Let's see, Eran.
Cool, thanks for
the presentation.
It looks super cool and
probably really fun to use.
My question is really about
how you plan to get this out
there and market it.
This seems like a
consumer play to me.
You said that
you're not planning
to target schools initially.
And so if you're going
directly after parents
and junior high
school kids, how do
you compete with the
billions of marketing dollars
that are already going out there
by all the major companies?
That's true.
It's a real challenge for us.
We have a few strategies
to get started.
The first is to begin locally
and use public institutions
like libraries as
a place to launch
these, gain publicity,
one-on-one, in person
with people.
And then there's
specific user segments
that we're looking at, like the
home school community, which
is very, very plugged in.
They have their own
culture in a sense.
And so we're targeting
those individuals subsets
of customers, and
we're going to try
to market to them individually.
But I would say the
grassroots, on the ground,
in libraries and communities
and after-school centers, that's
how we get the publicity that
we think people will react to.
All right, Josh.
Nice presentation.
And of course, it's
an interesting time
and a good time for
a product like this.
You spoke a bit
about the market.
And it seems clear you're
delivering some real value here
in these kits.
I'm wondering if you have
a sense of costs involved
in all of these various
kits, the production of them,
where your profit margins might
lie in a project like this
given that it's so
physical and there's
shipping involved, et cetera.
Yeah, I'll take this one.
Yeah, we've been
looking at costs,
and we agree that we're a
very traditional startup
in that sense because our
profits will be directly
from the product and not so
much from an online platform
or something like that.
So we have been
considering that.
And we've also been looking into
partnering with art supplies
companies so that
we get everything
at a discounted price.
But really where we see
adding value to our products
is the challenges that we'll
be implementing in there.
So our idea is to have
open-ended challenges
so that each student develops a
completely different thing out
of whichever kit they pick.
So no two final products
will be the same.
So I think the
value in our product
would really be in those in
those prompts and challenges
that will be coming and
not so much from-- so I
think we will be able to
make a profits on that.
All right.
Wendy.
Great, thank you.
Question for you.
It's one thing for you to
get the kit in the mail.
It's another thing to actually
get the kids to open it up,
and to do it.
Wondering what's
going to make it--
get them to actually engage.
Is there a social
media aspect, take
your picture on Instagram,
what's that whole integration?
Sure.
So although this is
mostly a physical product,
the one digital
component we have
that we think is
really important
is an online
platform for students
to post images of their work,
see what other students have
made with the same curriculum
or with other curriculum.
And I think all of us who are
engaged in any kind of studio
practice or education
right now, we're
seeing how valuable
studio culture
and seeing one another
in a space actually is.
So we know that the
small digital component
of our venture has to
do that, and basically
produce studio culture
online in a way that's
distributed and would allow
people across the country
to see one another's work.
All right.
Gui, thank you.
That sounds really interesting.
I'm curious, I wish
the presentation
had a little bit more detail
on what goes inside of the box.
I think that's
potentially something
that sounds really fun.
I think people would like
to see a little bit of stop
motion there, which is
something that I do.
So I'm curious like how
would you approach someone
to learn to do
something like that
and make it fun,
but also open ended
enough to be creative, but
clear enough to explain people.
So I would like to
know more about--
to me, it's really all
about what's in the box
and how you're going to do that.
I don't think
you're going to have
a quick explanation for
that, so more of a comment
about the presentation.
This will be our last response.
Thank you so much.
Yeah, we've actually
been developing
three of those products
that we'll be launching.
And the common theme
amongst all of them
is that it will have
three different prompts.
And the first one, it will be
like a scaffolded learning.
So the first one will
be very straightforward,
teaching the student
the basic skills.
The second one the student
will build those up
on those skills that were
already in Challenge One.
And there they will be able
to be a bit more creative.
And then the third one
will be the final one that
will be completely
open-ended using the skills
that they've already developed
and the other challenges.
And the idea from
that came from--
both Michael and I
have been teaching
and I'm actually currently
doing a teaching certificate
program at MIT.
So we're implementing all
of those teaching techniques
that we've been using and
that we're currently learning,
as well, into the kits.
So we're really going to try
to scaffold that learning
so that the final
thing that they would
be able to do in the
kit will be completely
personal and individual
to each student.
All right, thank you
so much, Team ELEMENTS.
Up next, we've got
Material Futures Lab.
Hi there.
So if we look around
the Zoom call--
and now that we're all home--
as well in our
closets, we can quickly
determine that we all wear
a lot of colored clothing.
And that's awesome,
because colored clothing
makes us feel and look great.
And actually, the practice
of coloring textiles
has been around for
thousands of years
and is a culturally
significant practice.
The Navajo tribe, for
instance, in the United States,
creates these beautiful
weaving charts,
such as the one you see on
screen, to document and keep
track of the plant matter
that they use to create
their colored dye stuffs.
But unfortunately, a
lot of these practices
are only capable to be
done on a small scale
and they're not easily scalable.
So we end up looking
at a lot of images
like this when we think
of the textile industry.
Unfortunately, the
textile industry
is actually responsible for
20% of global water pollution
and it's the second-most
polluting industry
after the oil industry.
And so the current method
of coloring fabrics
involves using synthetic
dyes and these are often
treated with toxic
chemicals and heavy metals.
They do not
decompose, and so that
means the same dye stuffs that
were used to color fabrics
150 years ago are still
persisting in our soils
and in our waterways.
And unfortunately, their
plant dye counterparts
are actually not much better.
Plants are incredibly
resource-intensive,
they require acres of land,
years of growing time,
and several hundred
liters of water to grow.
And in fact, indigo farmers
in the United States
have reported that it
requires them to grow up
to 13 acres of indigo
dye plants to color
just one acre of cotton fiber.
And so to put the global
problem into perspective,
the total market size of dyes
and pigments manufacturing
is estimated at $49 billion
and is growing at 5% per year
due to sustainable innovation.
We see the textile
industry, specifically,
starting to respond
to these changes,
to promote more sustainable
products and processes
due to increasing regulations
on wastewater treatment,
and consumer preferences
for environmentally
friendly processes.
At Material Futures
Lab, we have developed
a process which
turns microorganisms
into miniature dye factories.
We are able to produce really
brightly-colored pigments,
such as the purple-blue one you
see on screen, that don't fade
due to light or in washing.
We have proven our process
at the bench scale,
and we are now beginning to
scale our production process.
Some of the key benefits of this
approach to producing pigments
is that our powders can
be easily substituted
for synthetic pigments
that are used currently.
We can control our
growing conditions
to ensure high yields
and consistent color.
And we can scale our process
using existing manufacturing
to meet global demand.
We aim to restore the
tradition of natural dyeing
on a large scale by leveraging
biotechnology and process
engineering.
We see our technology
actually translating
across multiple scales.
Despite the work
that we're doing
being mainly at the
scale of a cell,
this type of
sustainable production
actually results in cleaner
and safer conditions
of the dye house.
As well, we promote a
more sustainable economy
and global market.
So we are really
excited, actually,
to be announcing our partnership
with lululemon athletica.
We've been in contact with
them for a while, and even
through the
coronavirus era, we're
going to be applying
our technology
to color their athletic
wear and their leggings.
They're an incredible
partner, they're
leaders for sustainable
fashion, and they're
reshaping the fashion
industry to adopt
more sustainable technology,
and we're privileged and humbled
to have their support.
Joe and myself bring
a wealth of experience
in couture fashion,
sustainable design,
including textile design
and metabolic engineering.
We're also supported by amazing
mentors, such as Dr. Valerie
Ward.
She is by training a
bioprocess chemical engineer--
[DING] One minute.
And is supporting
our scale-up process.
Aithan is also an
artist by training,
and involved with the
Sloan School at MIT.
He has been providing
us with mentorship
on how to build out our art
space technology actually
into a sustainable
business model.
So we plan to use the $15,000
from the MIT Creative Arts
Competition actually to
file a patent on our process
and to start scaling our
manufacturing to meet demand.
So at Material Futures
Lab, we believe
in a world that's designed
with and for nature,
and we hope to bring this
technology to your closets
and Zoom calls very soon.
Thanks so much, and we will
now take your questions
and your comments.
Thanks.
All right.
Thank you, Iris.
And let us turn--
Mary.
Let's hear from you, please.
Thank you.
Yes, this is a really
exciting product and idea,
but I was wondering if you could
just talk a little bit more
about how this works.
I don't really have
a good understanding
of how you're using
microorganisms to create dyes
yet, from your presentation.
Yeah, so I guess in the kind
of short way to explain it,
microorganisms produce a number
of compounds and one of them,
in our case, is pigments.
And so we're able to
leverage the processing
power of microorganisms
to produce our pigments.
We've developed an
environmentally-friendly
process of actually
harvesting those pigments
and powderizing them.
And it's the pigment powders
that we're actually selling.
All right.
Next, Mark.
Do you have a question?
Oh, you're muted.
You're muted.
I'm sorry.
OK, go ahead.
I couldn't hear you.
Can you hear me now?
Yes.
How dependent if at all are
you on government regulation?
In terms of--
Yeah.
So a huge push
towards our technology
is actually that a lot
of pigment manufacturing
has a lot of
regulation around it.
And so in our case, we're using
lot of sustainable chemistry
and nothing is against the
processes of like heavy metals
or anything like that.
And so that's actually
a huge incentive
for companies like lululemon
to switch to our product.
All right.
Phillip.
First, I really--
I think there's a huge--
I love how you've identified the
issues with the current market.
This is a big problem.
So I love to see how you're
bringing innovation to it.
I think that the piece
that's missing for me is--
I think you've already
started to answer in
that you've already gotten this
pre-commercial relationship
with lululemon, but what
is the business model?
Like you're selling pigments.
I mean, how are
you going to scale
that production, if you're
at the bench level now.
Like that's my big question.
Thanks.
OK, I can answer that for you.
So we're going to
be using CMOs who
have bio-fermentation
equipment already
to actually just convert
our process and scale that.
And then we're going to be
doing some post-processing
in our labs and then be shipping
that directly to our customers.
So our customers range from end
users like brands, lululemon,
who work up their supply chains.
They also can include companies
like paint manufacturers,
artist paints,
plastics manufacturers,
and we're in contact with
a bunch of those companies,
as well.
Wonderful.
Wendy.
Oh.
You kind of addressed
it all, but I was just
thinking about what are
the other uses for this,
and like, why did you pick the
clothing industry, as opposed
to something it might be a
little easier to get into?
So--
Yeah, no.
It's a very fair point.
We see that paints and
plastics, they definitely
have a use for these.
They're less consumer-facing
in their manufacturing,
and so we think
that environmentally
and sustainably we want to
be promoting that message.
And so, textiles is a
really great way to do that.
We all wear clothes.
Well--
Yeah.
[CHUCKLING]
All right.
And I think I have time
for one more from Eran.
Cool.
So, can you actually
make all the colors?
Yeah, so we're producing a
blue-purple pigment right now.
We're also looking at red.
The idea is to go trichromatic
so that we can mix.
OK, but-- so that's
not a concern, right?
Like I imagine
that the buyers are
going to want to have a
large palette of colors,
you know, that's probably
what they're used to.
And so that's not like a
technical challenge for you?
It's something that we believe
we can really overcome.
As well, in our
conversations we hear a lot
that blue and red pigments
tend to be the most toxic.
And so those are actually the
ones, if we can produce those,
they provide a really
good alternative.
There's a number of yellow
and kind of orange pigments,
like turmeric and things like
that, which are manufactured
for food processing.
So being able to produce
blue pigments, for instance,
that are stable to heat
and light has a value.
Cool.
All right, wonderful.
Thank you.
Thank you all for that.
I think at this point,
we will now move on.
Last but not least,
to Team UnMake.
[INAUDIBLE] sustainable
and natural materials
in the art production process.
The idea originated
10 years ago when
I started experimenting
with sustainable materials
while working with some of
the most influential artists
in the world.
Their practices made a huge
impact on my thought process,
and I try to convert
it into this company.
Sustainability plus art
is a multicultural concept
that is being followed across
several cultures in the world.
And millennials are leading
this race, currently.
Our primary research
proves that tens of artists
want to really work with
sustainable materials
and are highly inclined
towards sustainability.
The online art sales of
a market of $4.6 billion
and this sustainable product
sales of $150 billion
just goes on to prove
that sustainability
is on a rapid rise.
So the whole world is moving
towards sustainability,
the online art
markets are rising,
and the consumer section
is growing rapidly.
But this market is
currently very segmented
and it needs a huge
reconnection and a bridge.
And that's where we come in.
We lie at the intersection
of the sustainability market,
the art industry, and the
rising consumer section.
We are bridging the gap between
sustainability and the art
industry by connecting
sustainable, locally-sourced
materials, and those
materials producers.
This is our production strategy.
An artist uploads their
work on our platform.
We produce it using recycled
paper and recycled ink.
Then, we use the city-specific
metal, or bamboo,
or wooden frame to reproduce it.
And then, we distribute
it to the customer.
Our scaling strategy is simple.
We are only going to scale up
city wise, based on the art
awareness, ease of
production and delivery,
and sustainability
consciousness of the cities.
And we are going to deliver
only within the city premises
to avoid shipping and keeping
the carbon footprint minimal.
We have started
operations in two art
conscious global cities,
New York and Bombay,
and our research proves that
they are totally logistically
suitable for our work.
Our value proposition
is multi-fold.
We are encouraging a
global community of artists
across the world
to come together.
We are fostering a
combination of local
plus global
intercultural fusion.
We are cultivating
environmental consciousness.
We are providing
business opportunities
to emerging and individual
artists across the world.
And we are enhancing
the local art and craft
and boosting the local
economy of the cities.
We are going to partner with
artists, material suppliers,
local craftspeople,
delivery vendors,
as well as the local
printing studios who
will give us the
space and let us
do the work in their studios.
Our revenue model comprises
of the royalties held
by the artists and
our production cost,
and we are going to charge
15% of the total cost.
This is a hypothesis
customer scenario
in which a Japanese artist
puts her work on our platform.
A Bombay girl likes the work
and orders it on UnMake.
Our in-house craftsman Ravi
prints the Japanese art
on old Indian Dhoti cloth
and with natural pigment
and ancient print technique.
And then the artwork is
delivered to Madhuri.
She loves the artwork framed
with vernacular Indian material
and the Japanese art.
We have already just received
750-plus registrations
from all over the world, and
50-plus high-quality artworks
are there on our
website already,
which you can check
on our website.
We're being supported by
MIT Sandbox Innovation
Fund and the MIT
Innovation Initiative,
and of course, MIT
Creative Arts Competition.
The images that you
see in the background
are all signed by the artists
from around the world.
With the $15K, we are going
to test the physical product,
and this money will also
help us in the outreach.
We're researching about
the competitive analysis,
and we figured that the business
model of the current players
does not deal with
sustainability at all.
And we lie somewhere
between players
like Etsy and Framebridge,
and we provide a sustainable
alternative to them.
Our team comprises of
professional artists,
financial experts,
technical experts,
and we've all been working
together for several years.
I am an architecture
student here at MIT,
and I recently headed
the MIT India Initiative,
which was MIT's
largest student-run
initiative in India.
Our team also comprises of
professors and advisors who
have been working in the art
sector for several years,
in addition to the domain and
technical expertise provided
by the MIT Sandbox
and Arts at MIT.
We've been partnering
with hundreds
of several local artists
in India and the US,
and they're very happy
to team up with us.
We're also teaming up with
prospective influencers
like Stella McCartney,
Bobby Sager,
and these people are very happy
to be involved in our project.
We have conducted
several workshops
related to local material use.
This recent one was
in Taipei, in which
we asked the people
to go in their city
and bring local materials.
And we were trying to
understand their relationship
and their idea about
local materials.
One minute.
These are our future plans.
In the next phase, we
are going to penetrate
into the underprivileged regions
to reach out to the artists
there.
We are going to use eco-friendly
transportation, like e-bikes
and bicycles, and local
public transportation.
We are going to partner
with art galleries, museums,
and art festivals in the
analysis of the world.
In the Phase 3, we
are going to expand
into cities which put
environment first, for example,
Copenhagen and Amsterdam.
We are going to
launch an auction
on our website in
which the artist will
get much more exposure.
We are going to use technology
to review the artwork so
that we maintain high-quality
work on our website.
And finally, we are going
to build an institution
around the core
idea of UnMake that
matches art and sustainability.
So overall, we are
setting the art industry
as an example in the move
towards sustainability, which
will inspire other industries
to move towards a sustainable
future.
Thank you.
Thank you so much, Piyush.
Let's get right
into some questions.
I see that Josh has his hand up.
Hi, thank you for
the presentation.
In viewing your
slides as a customer,
I want to know a bit more
about the quality I can expect.
I'm curious to know--
I didn't see any specific
physical prototypes.
Could you speak
a little bit more
about the quality of the
bamboo frames, the brightness
of the inks, the materials
and what a customer can
expect on that level?
So that is explained
by our partnerships,
and we've been partnering
with several organizations who
are working with these materials
in India and in the US.
Right now, we don't have a
physical prototype to show you,
but our partnerships show that
these people have been working
on that and we can produce
a high-quality product
with the help of these
experienced stakeholders.
All right.
How about Mark?
Make of any particular painting?
Sorry, me?
Mark, can you
please repeat that?
Is there is a
limit on the number
of copies you would make
for a given painting?
No, it totally
depends on the artist.
And it's not just paintings.
It's paintings, photographs,
digital artwork illustrations,
any kind of visual art.
So you don't envision--
there would probably not
be a secondary market for
this work, or there might be?
Yes, so our business model
actually provides transparency
and uniqueness in which
the artist is allowed
to do their own
business on the side
and our model will actually
enhance their existing business
by using the
sustainability narrative.
All right, let's
hear from Wendy next.
Piyush, how are you?
Sorry about that.
Good, how are you Wendy?
I'm great, I'm great.
Hey, quick question.
How are you going
to vet your artists?
Or are you?
Sorry, can you come again?
How will you vet your artists?
How will you decide
who's the lucky ones who
gets to upload their artwork?
Yeah, so as I said, we
have professional artists
on our team and we will be
doing a careful curation
of the artwork that we receive.
And we have already-- if
you go to our website,
you'll see a bunch of
artworks which we have already
curated and put on the website
and we took several days
to choose the best artworks.
And also we are reading the
background of the artists,
their experience
in the industry,
and their relevance
to our product.
Thank you.
Wonderful, thank you.
Let's have a question
from Phillip next, please.
Hi.
So I mean, I see your drive
towards sustainability
as a differentiator.
The product as I see it, is
a on-demand poster printing
service with a custom frame.
Is that correct?
No, that's not actually true.
If you look at your
value proposition--
can you see my slide?
No.
Can you see my screen?
You're not screen
sharing because we've
stopped screen sharing for
the deliberation portion.
For the Q&A portion.
So I think that's a
very good question,
and I would like
to make it clear
that it's not just a
business of selling art.
We are trying to connect local
and global artists together
by our venture.
So for example, if you're an
artist sitting here in the US,
you publish your work in our
platform and a person in India
likes it, they buy it, and
we with our local partners,
produce it using
sustainable materials
and with the help of
the local Indian craft,
we are going to make it.
So it's a bridge of different
art cultures together.
There's the primary
value proposition.
So it's not just that it gives
money or business opportunity
to the artist, but also
boosts the local economy
and local craft.
All right.
Let's hear from Gui.
You're muted, Gui.
Gui?
Sorry.
So just expanding on
Philip's question.
You're going to be a
curator of those artists.
So artists are
going to be invited
to participate in
this whole environment
that you are creating
that produces
that the copies of the
work and et cetera.
So you're going to do
like some management
and curation of the artists,
not just produce the copies?
Yeah, exactly.
So we're not just
looking at artworks,
we're also looking at the
artist and his overall team,
his works, his
experience, and the kind
of artwork he produces.
And then we are
going to also talk
with our local
partners, our craftsmen,
if these artworks are relevant
to what they feel, you know,
what they believe in.
So it's a partnership with the
local craftsmen, as well as
the artists.
OK.
So just to be clear, like
if I'm not part of this
and I want to print my own
artwork in sustainable ink
and frame it sustainably
and all that stuff,
I'm not going to be allowed--
you're not going to provide
that service to third parties?
Just for your own artists?
No, why not?
I mean, you can definitely
reach out to us.
There's a form on our website.
If you fill that form,
and you upload your work,
we read your work right away.
And then we see if you
fulfill our conditions.
Then we'll definitely put
your work on our website.
OK.
So it's transparent and
it's open to everyone.
The only things we
are we are considering
is that the artwork should
not incite violence,
and it should not provide--
it should not give
anti-sustainable ideas
to the audience.
All right.
Thank you so much, Team UnMake.
Thank you all for your
wonderful pitches.
It was really exciting
to hear all of those.
Thank you!
So now, the judges
will be departing
for approximately 45
minutes of deliberation.
Now, I invite you to submit
questions to our teams
and enjoy some conversation
about these pitches
that you've just heard.
We'll begin with questions that
were submitted via the Q&A box,
and then we'll be
allowing attendees
to be unmuted for the rest
of the conversational portion
of the webinar, if there
is time for such a thing.
Following some Q&A, we'll be
holding the Audience Choice
voting.
So please cast a
vote to determine
who will win a $500 prize.
And then we'll hear an update
from our 2019 15K winning team.
Mark Adams will be here
from Teach to Learn
to give you an update about
all the exciting things
that they've done
since they won the 15K.
And I hope you enjoy the
conversation, the voting,
and the update, and we'll
return shortly for our finale
to reveal this year's winners.
Thank you all so much.
See you soon.
Hi, everyone.
So the first submitted
question was for ArcLive.
The question was-- This sounds
like a really cool startup that
fills a niche, untapped market.
He's wondering how the
partnerships are going
and if you have any feedback
on the product so far.
ArcLive, do you
want to take that?
Sure.
Partnerships were going well
until the coronavirus hit.
It's been rocky over
the past few months
because a lot of archives have
just completely shut down.
We've been talking with MIT, the
main MIT archives and the Aga
Khan Documentation Center here.
We're looking to
get into Harvard.
We've been prioritizing
a lot of the--
specifically in Boston--
a lot of larger ones.
After we focus on Boston,
we'll probably head to New York
next just because it's like
a four hour drive there.
So that's pretty good.
And then we'll be focusing
all the major cities probably
on the west coast,
like LA, San Francisco.
Great.
Maybe just to--
Audience members feel
free-- sorry, go ahead.
Go, Derek.
Sorry, Susan.
I was just going to say, we
see a lot of potential, too,
in the private sector to partner
with private sector enterprises
specifically with Ancestry.com,
which is a $650 million
business.
We see a lot of
opportunity there.
They have some open
access to public records.
But when it comes to
actual archival access,
those are restricted.
And we see partnership
opportunities with them
to get our product out there
through our subscription model.
Great, thank you.
And just for the audience, feel
free to submit any questions
into the Q&A or you
can raise your hands
and we can put you on video.
I see we just had one come
in for Material Futures Lab.
Are you considering working
with small artists, designers,
hand-makers, who are big
supporters of sustainability
in textiles?
This background is awful.
Yeah, I think we definitely are.
Right now, we're very interested
actually to start producing
at a large enough
quantity that we
can be creating enough supply
to reach people like that.
We're definitely interested
in partnerships as well.
So if you are interested,
send us an email.
[CHUCKLING] I have no
idea how Zoom works.
Yeah, you can send us an email
or get in touch with Shannon
and just let us know and
we're happy to get in touch.
So just some general
questions for everybody.
What has been the most enjoyable
aspect of this competition?
I know it's been sort of
a long ride this year,
and a lot of
differences, obviously,
in the last couple of months.
What's been the most enjoyable
part of the competition so far?
Does anyone want to
answer that on this?
Oh yeah, go for it.
Yes, I think what was
really interesting,
particularly
pre-COVID times when
we're able to all be together,
was the mentorship sessions
and then also taking that
onto Mentorly digitally.
But it was a really
interesting way
of allowing all of the
groups to engage and learn
from one another and grow
their pitches and business
development, regardless of
whether you were a finalist
or not.
So I thought those opportunities
were fantastic as a learning
opportunity for all of us.
Great, thanks.
Does any else want
to field that one?
OK, great.
So a question for UnMake.
Are artists allowed to make
sustainable copies of artworks
through UnMake?
Yes, definitely.
They're allowed to
make sustainable
copies of their artworks, yes.
For P(art)ner, do you
have any partnerships that
you've already established or
interest that you've seen from
real estate developers?
Would you seek out partnerships
from city governments as well?
Yeah, absolutely.
We would love to
partner with Boston.
The City of Boston, they
just started a really awesome
Percent for Art
Program that they're
testing out and
piloting right now.
And also in San
Francisco, because that's
where Natasha and
I are currently
based in the two coasts.
We first met Sebastian,
who's building out
this really awesome adaptive
reuse community near Davis
Square, and we just really want
to be aligned with developers
who are artists themselves or
really care about social impact
and are very mission-driven.
So we're really going
after those developers
and have been in a lot of
great conversations with them.
Thanks.
Great.
Another question for UnMake.
As an artist, if I
send you something
depending on what materials
are used at every level,
the maker's choices will
produce different results,
some that I might not like.
Will there be a proofing
process for both the artists
and the buyers?
Yes.
So, our process involves
the collaboration
of both the
participating artists,
as well as the craftsmen.
And whatever
material we produce,
whatever the final
product is, it
involves both the artist,
as well as the craftsman.
And if the artist does
not want a particular kind
of craft attached
to their artwork,
they are free to tell us that.
Great, thank you.
What's been the most important
lesson that any of the teams
have learned
throughout the process?
I know for many of you it's
been a very long process
and some shorter, but
are there any sort
of major landmarks that felt
like big discoveries learned?
Tricky question, I'm sure.
Sorry, Rarify, did
you have an answer?
Go for it.
Yeah, I mean, I think this was
a great opportunity to really
dive into, for instance,
a business plan.
And so having the time and
accountability to devote
to looking at a business
plan and seeing critiques,
seeing how relevant and acute
the feedback was from those
that we receive feedback from.
And so you know,
it's always it's
interesting when
you're speculating,
OK, what's your revenue going
to be, and all this stuff.
But at least being able
to have the opportunity
to look through,
investigate, speculate,
and try to be as accurate
and rigorous as possible.
Great.
Thank you.
A question came
in for P(art)ner.
Do you have any
idea of the number
of local artists
capable or eager
to work at the public art scale?
The idea here is that
some folks might not
realize that they're
perfect for public art.
Maybe they work with fabric,
or other materials that
aren't 2D or 3D in the same
way that large-scale art is,
but that they've
never really realized
their potential that way.
And so because we're really
leaning on reaching out
to non-profit arts organizations
that have a lot of artists
and residents,
we're really hoping
that folks at these non-profits
can kind of be curating
and introducing artists
to these new ideas
because they really know
their artists pools well.
Are you picturing
having opportunities
for both physically
smaller-scale public art, as
opposed to just gigantic
murals and that kind of thing?
I think that's one
of the questions,
is that if you're not a
muralist or a sculptor,
is there an opportunity there?
I think that we want to--
No, go ahead.
We definitely want to address
the fact that art doesn't have
to just be murals, especially
for the public art realm,
it's really interesting
to hear what
the different regulations are.
For example, in
Massachusetts, public art
can only be sculptural in 3D.
And then in
California, public art
can be extended towards live
performances, and exhibitions,
and word speech.
So we really want to
expand on what art is.
And then in terms of
the previous question,
in terms of the
number of artists,
as part of our
business plan we want
to create a curated experience
so that every single city
we would only be representing
about 60 artists.
So we do want to be mindful
about diluting the pool.
Great, thank you.
A couple more
questions for UnMake.
One, just how the
name came about.
And also, if you have
a economic breakdown
for each section of the process.
So right now, as I
explained in the slide,
that we have calculated
the production cost based
on the material price plus
the price of the construction
that includes the labor cost,
as well as the cost of printing.
And in New York,
it's around $58,
and in Bombay it's around $25.
Does that answer your question?
We'll see if the Question
Answer writes back.
And how did the name come about?
Yes, the name.
It basically comes
from the process
of using recycled materials
because everything that is made
creates a carbon footprint.
And since we are only using
recycled and sustainable
materials, we are
unmaking that process.
That's why we are called UnMake.
Great.
Thank you so much.
I think one of the
most valuable parts
from an outside perspective
for this competition
is the great access
that you all have
to a really wide
variety of mentors
and some of the judges
and that feedback process.
What's been some of
the most useful advice
that you've gotten from
mentors throughout this?
ArcLive, do you want
to answer that one?
Yes, sure.
I'm happy to.
Yeah, the Mentorly
resources were great.
I think they really
forced us to ask
how we can leverage our
technology to also gain access
to copyrighted material so
that we're not simply putting
in workstations, but
actually gaining access
to those copyrights.
There's a lot of
potential future revenue
that could be derived
if we can do so.
So that was certainly
something that's
forced us to rethink a
bit how we move forward.
Did any of them the other teams
have really useful feedback
that helped shape how their
presentations have developed
over the course of the year?
Sure, I can respond
to that quickly.
Both Maria and I, we don't
come from business backgrounds.
We're architects by training.
So in a sense, this
was our first time
trying to develop
a business plan
and all the things that
are associated with that.
So I would say the
mentors really lasered in
on all of our blind spots
and showed us the questions
we didn't even know to ask,
so that by the end of this
we were able to kind
of sharpen the idea
and get some where hopefully
somewhat convincing.
That's great, thank you.
Rarify, had you wanted
to answer that one?
Sure, I was just
going to say that it's
been really nice to work
through with our mentors
and with other peers, the story
that we're telling and making
sure that our
passion comes across
because our venture
is so personal to us
as everyone's is.
So really, telling a
story has been something
that we've loved working on.
Fantastic.
Thank you so much.
One question came in
for Material Futures.
What sort of performance
testing have you
performed on your
biologically-produced pigments?
Do they bleach in the sun?
Will they withstand washing
at high temperatures?
Et cetera.
Sorry--
It's performance-- Huh?
No, sorry.
I think we just typed an answer.
OK, great.
You beat me to it.
That's great.
Awesome.
Are there any
differences between
the performance and
utility of these pigments
and other commercially,
industrial made ones
that you've found so far?
Yeah, we can talk about that.
So of course synthetic
pigments they're
made often with
metals, heavy metals
and often have very,
very strong fastness.
That's kind of what they've
been designed to do,
or specific
performance attributes.
And so our pigments
are organic pigments.
So by nature,
they're biodegradable
and they're fully organic.
So their lifespan is likely
not going to be as long.
We have had really good
results for life fastness
and washing up to temperatures
of 120 degrees so far,
but we're going to
be rigorously testing
over the next couple of
months to really determine
exactly what specs we have.
So yeah, hopefully we'll
be able to determine that.
Great.
Well I imagine with lululemon
you'll get a pretty good crash
course in how durable
they are for extreme use.
[CHUCKLING]
[CHUCKLING] For sure.
One more question for UnMake.
How do you foresee
the art industry
setting the
sustainability narrative?
I'm not sure if I
understood the question,
but what I understood
from that I can answer.
We can see that the art
industry right now is basically
quite fragmented.
There is and there's a whole
sustainability area in the art
industry which has not
yet been leveraged enough,
and the artists
really want to work
with sustainable materials.
That we got to know
with our interviews
and also with the research.
And if we let them use
the sustainable materials
and also make profit
out of it, that's
going to make a change
in the industry.
Great.
Thank you so much.
I think unless anyone
has any other questions
from the audience,
we will move forward
with the audience choice
voting, which is very exciting.
So our colleague Dana will put
up a slide, just so everyone
can remember who
they're voting for,
and I will start the poll now.
We'll give about five
minutes for everyone to vote,
and then we'll come back with
a quick video from last year's
15K, and then Teach to
Learn's presentation update.
So please feel free to vote
for your Audience Choice now.
Each team will have five minutes
to pitch, everybody knows that.
They will then have five minutes
for questions and answers
after their pitch.
The 15K Creative
Arts Competition
is for student
arts-focused businesses.
So this is an area of
arts entrepreneurship
that tends to mix the
Arts, and technology,
and sciences up in
very interesting ways.
Well, first of all,
I think MIT is just
an incredibly creative place.
There are so many
creative people here.
I remember as a student just
thinking that, in a sense,
art was everywhere.
As a woman of color and as
a citizen on this Earth,
I have some concerns.
The parameter for
applying is really just
to have an idea, even if
you're a solo entrepreneur.
Because after you apply, there
are six weeks of mentoring
and networking and workshops,
so that at the end of April
at Live Pitch Day, you have
a strong business plan,
you've considered
your market, you've
considered your path to market,
you've considered your team,
your value prop, and all
of the other things that's
an important business has.
The mentorship component really
helped us rethink some of our--
the way we're presenting
our ideas, and even
some of our business
model questions.
So that was really helpful.
I think the most important
thing is not the result.
It's the process
during the competition.
We're seeing a lot of
technological disruption
in the Arts, and MIT being
a leader in technology,
it just needs to be
involved in supporting
the Arts from a
technological perspective.
Great, thank you, Dana.
And now we have the
pleasure and privilege
of hearing from Mark
Adams from Teach to Learn.
Thanks Susan, can you hear me?
Yes, you sound great.
Great.
I'm going to go ahead
and share my screen.
Make sure you get
that audio in there.
It's really a pleasure to
be here joining you today
on Zoom, though we
wish you could be there
in person in the beautiful
venue we were last year.
But maybe next year, hopefully.
I'm here to give you a little
bit of an update on Teach
to Learn.
And I hope that you'll let me
know if you can't see this,
but Teach to Learn is a
global arts education network.
And really the
core of what we do
is using music as a
foundation for building
personal relationships and
a truly online community.
And our goal is really
to empower people
to share what they
know and love.
I'm going to quickly
show a video here.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Hi, my name is Sami Stevens.
I'm from East Winthrop,
Maine, usually
residing in Brooklyn, New York.
Right now, camping out in
Carrabassett Valley, Maine.
I sing and play a bit of keys,
and when I teach I learn.
- Hi, my name is
Alejo from Argentina.
- My name is Hakam and
I'm from Iraq, Mosul.
- Hi, my name is
Tatiana from Argentina.
- My name is Inap I'm from
the Nepal, from Kathmandu.
- Hi, I'm Camille.
I live in Auckland, New Zealand.
I play the oboe, and
when I teach, I learn.
[END PLAYBACK]
OK, looks like we have some
trouble with the video.
Susan, you couldn't
see that, right?
I couldn't see it,
I could hear it.
Oh, annoying.
And it's playing right now.
If you want, we can--
if there's a link
to it anywhere,
we can definitely put
that in the chat as well,
and have people
view it on YouTube
and come back if that's easier.
Sure.
OK, let me kill that one.
And we can figure out
how to do that after.
But OK.
No doubt that there was going
to be some technical challenges
to doing this.
Always.
[CHUCKLES]
But the purpose of
that video was just
to give you a little bit
of a personal connection
and face-to-face with a few of
our Fellows from our Fellowship
Program.
But some of the high level stats
of where Teach to Learn is.
We've been around for
about four years now.
And in that time, we've
had over 250 participants
in 20 countries
around the world.
And altogether,
they've connected
for more than 1,000 hours,
which is pretty amazing when
you think about where we
started from four years back.
Our programs started out of
really just a single one.
This mentorship program.
And you can think of our
programs in two buckets.
One-to-one, and one-to-many.
So when Teach to
Learn just started,
when our co-founders Derek
and Bob started making
matches of people playing
similar instruments
with similar musical
interests between musicians
all around the world, that
was our mentorship program.
That was a chance for--
especially students
in areas where
there wasn't access to
great musical resources
to connect with musicians all
around the world for lessons
and also out of that
cultural exchange and a lot
of interesting things that
came from those conversations.
And the demand for that was
really impressively high,
more than we anticipated.
And that's sort of
where we were when we
came into the 15K Competition.
That Mentorship Program had been
around for a couple of years,
and we were thinking
about how do we
take this to the next level.
And how do we grow this out,
what programs do we add.
And from that-- so we developed
another one-to-one program
called The Fellowship.
And the core of that is
really the peer exchange
with structured conversations
over the course of 10 months,
and funding for the Fellows
to create and execute
on collaborative
community projects,
whether that's around
music or something
in their community
related to the Arts.
So we were really excited to
launch the fellowship last year
and that was something
we'd been starting
to plan for and figure out
as we were going into the 15K
last year.
And in addition to those
one-to-one programs,
we also have two
one-to-many programs.
So the Classroom
Connect is a collection
of curated virtual music and
cultural exchange modules
that are offered in high
schools around the US,
and Global Music Seminars
are online courses
taught by musical faculty
from different places
around the world
at conservatories
in different countries
around the world.
So those are our
four main programs
just to give you a sense.
I mentioned a few
of these things
of where we've come from.
We launched the Mentorship
Program back in 2016.
In 2018, we joined
the MIT Sandbox,
which was a great starting
point for us in that journey
that I mentioned,
about rethinking
some of what Teach
to Learn would offer
and what we would
be in the future.
We had our first paid
customer in January 2019,
which was perfect
timing to enter
into this sort of
pre-competition mentorship
phase.
And we actually
got a lot of value
out of speaking with our mentor
during the 15K Competition,
thinking about how do we really
capitalize on that first paid
customer and think
about doubling down
on that part of our programming.
In April, we did we were
very, very excited to win
the Creative Arts Competition,
and it was also an exciting
month when we officially
received our 501(c)3
registration.
And then in October,
we launched two
of the new programs, the
Fellowship and the Global Music
Seminars.
And now, in spring
of 2020, we've
expanded the Classroom
Connect program
to three high schools
in the Boston area,
and we are really excited for
the Fellowship projects, too.
They're just starting to wrap
up their 10 months in the coming
months and the Fellows are
starting to implement and work
on their community projects.
We're actually working
right now to get funding
to one of our Fellows who's
ready to go in Argentina.
He's working on a really
interesting children's book,
mapped to music.
It should be really cool.
So that's just
starting to happen,
and within a couple of
months, we'll be seeing all 26
of those projects finished
and all the awesome results
from around the world.
I want to just introduce
you to the team, in addition
to myself.
Derek and Bob and Shiaqi.
It's all four of us
volunteering our time,
this is a passion project for
us on the evening and weekends.
What drew us to
Teach to Learn was
all of our background
in music education,
and musicians
ourselves, the countries
we've worked in
around the world,
and all that experience meeting
and interacting with people
all around the world.
So it's a very
international team
and with a very
international focus.
For the 15K Competition,
just to give you
a little sense of how
that funding helped
us advance the organization.
A good chunk of that funding
went towards programming.
A big part of that was
towards the Fellowship proof
of concept.
So we had this idea, as a
bit of an ambitious idea
to do the Fellowship Program
when we didn't really
have the funds to
make it happen,
because we were funding
each of those Fellows
to do those community projects.
But it was a bit of
a chicken and egg
because we wanted
to get universities,
and maybe orchestras, and
other music programs involved
and sponsoring Fellows,
but we didn't really
have any kind of proof to
show what that program could
look like, what those results
would actually look like.
So the $15K could not have
come at a better time for us
to short circuit that cycle and
skip ahead to actually having
a proof of concept
now after 10 months,
that we can take to
build partnerships
with some of the partners
I mentioned and really
have tangible evidence
of the impact.
So in addition to
the proof of concept
for that flagship
program, it's also
helped us expand and
test different models
for Classroom Connect.
So that additional funding
has gone a long way
in growing that part
of the business.
And like I mentioned
earlier, we kind of
doubled down in that area
after some of our conversations
with our 15K mentor.
Thinking about, OK,
I guess if people
are willing to pay
for this service,
this is an area we should
really investigate and try
to perfect so that we can
support our hybrid business
model of both revenue
and individual donations
and grant funding.
So that was really good
advice and we ran with it.
On the other side,
we also put money
towards editing, and
developing, and producing
all of the really awesome
material that's been coming in.
Derek and Bob over the
last summer were traveling,
and I got to visit some
of our Fellows in person
and capture some of the
work that they're doing.
As well as the projects
are starting to ramp up,
and Fellows are documenting
their activities.
We just have a lot of really
interesting stuff coming in
that we want to turn
into compelling materials
and messaging that can help
us then bring these programs
or any of these programs
to the new partners.
And finally, we've
been investing
in building our own
platform online.
Right now, we're using readily
available, free-to-use tools
for the most part to
run these programs.
But our vision is to
have a place where
our Fellows and other
participants can come log in
and we can have more
control over the user
experience in the future.
But we're not quite there yet,
but we're to get there soon.
This is a little bit of a visual
on the Fellowship Program,
just to give you a sense of--
88,000--
Mark, I think we can't--
I think we can't see your
screen at the moment.
I'm so sorry.
You can't see it.
I think you've got
off screen share.
OK, let me exit this.
Have you not been able
to see it for a while?
A little bit.
Oh, great.
OK.
Let me jump back in here.
It still sounded great.
[CHUCKLES]
OK.
So, this is where I was.
Got it, perfect.
And OK, that was where
the funding went.
And now this is a visual
on the Fellowship Program.
So just saying that
it really gives you
a sense of scale in
terms of the connections
that are being made just
within the Fellowship Program.
88,000 kilometers between
26 Fellows and 16 countries.
It's pretty phenomenal when
you really put it on a map,
and it's such an
amazing group of people.
We had the pleasure
recently of connecting
with everyone in three
separate Zoom calls,
just as a midpoint check-in.
And you know, we, as most
organizations right now,
are having to figure out how to
adapt many of these activities
and our activities
due to COVID-19,
but we're in a
pretty good position
of already being online-first
and having the tools set up
to do that.
So you know on the
one hand, yes, we
are connecting over Zoom like
everybody else these days.
But, even if things
were different
we would still have to connect
over Zoom because we can never
get everybody
in-person together.
But the Fellows are
really thinking creatively
and working hard right now
at adapting their projects
to make them safe for themselves
and their communities.
And we had some
really awesome ideas
a couple of months ago
that needed to be changed,
and what they're coming up with
now are also fantastic ideas.
So we're trying to be
iterative and flexible,
as well, as are our Fellows.
So I'll just leave
you with a video.
We're going to try again.
And Susan, interrupt
me if it's not working.
Will do.
Unless you guys just
want audio again.
This video is just to give you
a sense of one of our Fellows
in Calcutta.
[INAUDIBLE] Let's
see if this works.
[INAUDIBLE]
I can hear the audio.
I can't see it.
You might need to share the
actual screen, as opposed
to just the PowerPoint.
Right.
Yeah.
Maybe share your
desktop instead.
Sure.
That's probably what
happened last time.
[CHUCKLING]
OK.
All right, I'm closing this
and resuming the share.
And let's try this.
Can you see that right now?
Yes.
OK, let's try again.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- It's a way of life,
of expression, I guess.
It's really simple.
It's just how I can express
myself to the utmost.
[GUITAR STRUMMING]
I want them to be able
to express themselves
through various means available.
Things, various influences
go bottled in yourself
when you're coming from
these kinds of circumstances.
When you are considering
the places that I teach,
the way of life is
quite hard, so these
are pockets of spaces where
you can just concentrate
on expressing yourself without
thinking about the reality
that you're facing right now.
[END PLAYBACK]
Great.
I'm glad that that worked.
And now that I've
figured that out,
I'm going to try to
show you the other video
while I've still got you.
So let me know if
this does not work.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Hi, my name is Sami Stevens,
I'm from East Winthrop,
Maine, usually residing
in Brooklyn, New York.
Right now, camping out in
Carrabassett Valley, Maine.
I sing and play a bit of keys,
and when I teach, I learn.
- Hi, my name is
Alejo from Argentina.
- My name is Hakam, and
I'm from Iraq, Mosul.
- Hi, my name is
Tatiana from Argentina.
- My name is Inap, I'm
from Nepal, Kathmandu.
- Hi, I'm Camille.
I live in Auckland, New Zealand.
I play the oboe, and
when I teach, I learn.
- My name is Loujain Kronfoleh
from Damascus, Syria.
- My name is Roberto
Blanco, I am from Mexico.
- Hi, my name is Tanushree Vyas,
I am from [INAUDIBLE] India.
- My name is Kabuye Ronald.
I'm from Kampala, Uganda.
- Hi, my name is Julia.
I'm from California.
And I play the viola, and
when I teach, I learn.
[END PLAYBACK]
Great.
We did it.
I feel very accomplished.
I just want to say a really
big thank you from myself.
Derek, Bob, Shiaqi,
and everyone who
participates in Teach to Learn
and all the new participants
we've been able
to bring in thanks
to the funding and the support.
So really big thank
you to the 15K.
We've had a fantastic
experience with you,
and really it helped us advance
the organization drastically.
So thanks, and happy
to take any questions.
And please, feel free if
you're interested in the Arts,
if you're interested in
connecting, cultural music
exchange, or just want to
support what we're doing,
that's our info email there
on the screen and as well
our website.
Thank you so much, Mark.
What a fantastic presentation.
It's so wonderful to hear
about all the great things that
have happened for Teach
to Learn in the last year.
If there are any questions
from the audience,
feel free to put them into
the Q&A box right now.
We can answer those quickly.
And if there aren't
any, we will transition
into some videos about cast
and some of the other projects
that our office does while the
judges continue to deliberate.
We're hoping that we'll be
able to announce their decision
around 6:15 or so, but
again, deliberations always
flex a little bit.
So hopefully we're
able to announce things
as soon as we can.
I don't see any questions yet.
Mark, thank you so
much for joining us.
It's really a pleasure
to hear from you.
Yeah, great to be back.
Great to hear some of these
other pitches and good luck
to all the finalists.
Oh, I think I see one.
Oh, OK.
Tell us about some
of your struggles
and how you overcame
them over the past year.
Yes, great.
That's a great question.
We've had a lot of
bumps in the road.
You know, I think
COVID-19 is probably
the biggest that we've faced
because so much is riding
on so much time,
and honestly funding
has been invested into
the Fellowship Program
and the projects.
We really want to
see the results
and we were on track to see
some really exciting results,
and now with the pivot away
from in-person projects,
we really had to get creative
and support our Fellows
a lot more than we expected
to, or anticipated having
to do in the first place.
A way that we've done a pretty
good job addressing that--
by making sure that we reinforce
the community of Fellows
and for the Teach
to Learn community.
So having that midpoint
check-in was actually
the first time that we'd
had them in one place,
and after we did it,
we thought to ourselves
like why haven't
we been doing this
the whole time because
the energy was fantastic.
People were talking
to each other
and it wasn't just the
one-to-one, it was the group.
And people would say,
you know, I had this idea
now I don't know
what to do with it,
and then other people
say well, you know,
I had an idea like that, but
now I'm going to do this.
So you know having
those, we're actually
having another one
in a week, just
to keep the conversation going.
And basically, it's less
about us figuring everything
out and more about letting
our community connect
with each other to
help each other.
So there have been
other examples,
but that one has really
been one that I think
that we're going to
get over pretty well
and we're excited to see
what the projects are.
Great, well thanks
again for having us.
Appreciate being invited back
and sharing some of the updates
and please feel
free to reach out.
We're always happy
to talk to people.
We actually collaborated with
a few of the other finalists
from the 15K last
year, whether just
keeping in touch personally or
working on some side projects
together.
15K is a great way to
meet other people working
in Arts and Technology.
I think you're on mute,
Susan, but I will mute myself.
Yes, I am.
Thank you.
Thank you again so much
for coming and talking.
And it's that it's great to
hear that you're still in touch
with other people in the 15K.
That's awesome.
Thanks again.
Thank you.
So we will play a
couple of videos
about some other
programs that the Center
for Arts, Science &
Technology and other things
that the Arts at
MIT are working on.
And please watch this space.
We'll let you know as soon as we
have a result from the judges.
All right.
Welcome back, everybody.
The judges have completed
their deliberation.
After some very
lively discussions
about all of your
fantastic projects,
I am thrilled to announce
our winners of the 2020 15K
Creative Arts Competition.
Beginning with our
Audience Choice
Award in the amount
of $500, it is UnMake.
Congratulations to Team UnMake.
Moving on to our third prize
award in the amount of $1,000,
that will be going to
Material Futures Lab.
Congratulations!
And now for our second prize
in the amount of $2,500,
that goes to Rarify.
And finally, the
first prize winners
of the 2020 MIT Creative
Arts Competition, taking home
an incredible
$15,000 is ELEMENTS.
Congratulations!
Thank you to all of the teams
for your incredible effort,
for all of your hard work
throughout this entire process.
It's been an absolute joy
to work with all of you.
Thank you again to all of
the attendees, to our judges,
to the Office of the Arts,
to all of the mentors,
to Mentorly.
To everybody for
helping this to happen,
couldn't have done
it without you all.
And with that, I believe that we
have now concluded the 2020 15K
Creative Arts Competition.
Thank you all for being here,
for all of your support.
This has been a joy
and I look forward
to seeing you all in 2021!
Thank you so, so much.
Thank you.
Congratulations!
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Congratulations!
Congratulations,
great work everyone!
Congratulations.
Well done.